opposers I love America and I remember
what it was great I hope I'm not being
overly nostalgic when I say this but 100
cent of the things were 100 percent
better in the past
. no caveat I mean lately when I look
around I don't recognize my country
anymore first let's turn our eyes to the
worst state in the Union no Chuck even
worse Jesus
there she is California look at this
California taking the nanny state to a
whole new level forcing every new
homeowner to conserve energy by
mandating that they install solar panels
Bob Messi revealed he hates solar panels
I'm not a big solar panel guy yeah
Times Square Beethoven is right but to
be fair he's only saying that because he
doesn't believe in electricity at all
forcing people to install solar panels
is government overreach that's also
short-sighted I mean the Sun only has
about five billion years left in the
tank but you know what's infinite
gasoline baby
have you ever do run out of gas all we
have to do is kill some more dinosaurs
and I know just where to find them I'll
say it Jeff Goldblum's time has come
sorry Jeff asteroids coming I mean come
on
government-mandated solar panels where
am I
is this even America anymore you know
what maybe it's not maybe it's Morocco
and I'm riding the Marrakesh Express
into the sunset hunker down with my pals
around the hookah while I feed dates to
a little monkey who is my pet but also
understands human speech and does my
bidding in a Disney movie ah
enough with the charming mosaics in
UNESCO World Heritage Sites no Chuck get
me out of here
next up trucks
I love trucks they're just like America
loud unapologetic and constantly being
screamed at by the president well I just
found out that American Trucking is
changing according to a new study there
are approximately a hundred and fifty
thousand Sikhs in trucking and at this
point Sikhs make up 40% of trucking in
California look at the cover of my
third-favorite trucking industry
publication overdrive magazine hello hey
I'm all for having this guy on the cover
but Melania Trump hasn't been on the
cover of overdrive once not once here's
my problem
the truckers I know from TV and movies
are all about starting fights in road
houses the Sikh religion promotes peace
and tolerance how are they going to
threaten a guy with a broken pool cue if
they're busy building karma through good
deeds I don't get it how is this America
is this is this even America maybe it's
not maybe it's I don't know Lichtenstein
and I'm wandering around all 62 square
miles of it speaking German because
nothing says sovereign nation like
speaking another country's language and
being the size of an IKEA parking lots
Wow it's so nice to be in a country with
one of the highest per-capita GDP in the
world would adjust it for purchasing
power parity check get me out of here
finally cheerleaders when I went to high
school the coolest couple was the
cheerleader in the quarterback followed
closely by the president of Young
Republicans and his photograph of Pat
Buchanan but the reason the cheerleader
and the quarterback were so cool was
that they were special everyone wanted
to be them
well no anyone can the new jersey mom
went to her daughter's school to
complain because she didn't make the
cheer squad so guess what
now everybody makes the team everybody
Stephanie with an IE Stephanie with an
ey Stephanie with two FS and E and an M
lot because her dad thought it looked
like a smiley face everybody this is
ridiculous someone back me up here with
the reaction the pit bull of personal
development and author of the book
what's wrong with damn near everything
we call it on Larry winged it where
would you like to start well there are a
lot of places to start and stuff like
this is what's wrong with everything I
can tell you whoa hold the phone I like
this guy this book is called what's
wrong with damn near everything and
based on that information alone I had to
order his complete incredible library
I now own copies of and I promise these
are all real people are idiots and I can
prove it
shut up stop whining get alive you're
broke because you want to be your kids
are your own fault and finally the book
that I think most applies to these
wannabe cheerleaders grow up hair yes
Larry will whining cheerleaders is
exactly what's wrong with everything but
just like life after high school this
story gets worse normally whenever I'm
feeling outraged I can always rely on
Greg Gutfeld
fox news commentator and guy who
definitely still shouts party foul every
time someone drops a plate but listen to
how Greg reacts to this cheerleading
story I don't know here's my feeling
it's a small local story over a beef
over a cheerleading choice some parent
got ticked off now it's a national story
I guess I feel ambivalent Greg feels
ambivalent what's next is Juan Williams
going to actually try to win an argument
oh it's Jesse Watters going to not make
fun of Asian grandmother's what is this
it's not just not my country I don't
recognize the five anymore maybe I'm not
even watching the five maybe I'm
watching the Rachel Maddow Show on MSNBC
and it's just a full hour of snarky
sarcasm and Adam Schiff interviews where
he's simply flabbergasted maybe every
sentence of real news is preceded by 40
minutes of rudderless lead in that on
any given night might not be going
anywhere at all Chuck bring me back tell
me I'm still watching the shows I love
in the country I love Chuck are people
still more invested in NBC's The Voice
than the Russia investigation Kelly
Clarkson is super down-to-earth no
collusion trades
are there still more Avengers than there
are employees at the State Department's
for now yes but not if Thanos gets his
way okay is the effectiveness of torture
still up for debate just saying what if
it works oh yeah it never has but maybe
again Thank You Chuck I'm still at
America and that's still my five
[Music]